hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll and today we're gonna go back
into consciousness not just the easy
problem of consciousness how the brain
looks at the world and figures out what
is where and how to respond to it but
the hard problem of consciousness what
makes us who we are how we experience
the world what it is like to be us that
inner subjective first-person view that
we have of reality now if you've been
following me for a while you know that
I'm a naturalist
I'm a physicalist in fact which means I
think the world is made of stuff obeying
the laws of physics and that's basically
it except when that stuff comes together
to form complicated things like human
beings there can be new emergent
phenomena that arise and consciousness
is one of those consciousness is just an
aspect of the collective action of
underlying stuff obeying the laws of
physics but you will not be surprised to
learn that there are those who disagree
and those who disagree need not be
hardcore Cartesian duelists they don't
necessarily think that there's a
disembodied mind that somehow interacts
with the body it could also be true that
you believe the world is made of
physical stuff but the physical stuff
has extra properties mental properties
and this point of view drives you in the
direction of pan psychism thinking that
everything is a little bit conscious
it's not just that something new happens
when atoms and particles come together
to form a brain but there was something
that was there all along and it becomes
important and noticeable once you get
something like an organism or a brain so
for today's guest we have Philip Goff
who's a professor of philosophy at
Durham University in the UK and one of
the leading thinkers on pan psychism he
is all for it I am against it so we have
a very nice conversation
Philip is the author of an academic book
called consciousness and fundamental
reality and also a brand-new just
published popular level book called
Galileo's error foundation for a new
science of consciousness so I have fun
in the podcast with the idea that I'm on
Galileo side and Philip is against
Galileo side but basically Philip is
also Pro Galileo he thinks that Galileo
made a mistake in overly
using the world that we live in that
there's a qualitative aspect to the
world as well as a quantitative aspect
so you can listen to what we say back
and forth about both sides of this
mostly as usual I give Phillip a chance
to give his sales pitch for his side but
you can tell where my sympathies lie
remember that if you want to support the
podcast you can go to the webpage
preposterous universe comm slash podcast
there you can find transcripts of every
episodes and audio player and show notes
links to the person we're talking about
their Twitter bio and so forth you can
also find a patreon link so if you
support on patreon you get the podcast
without any ads and you also get a
monthly ask me anything episode and of
course you can go to Apple or iTunes and
leave reviews for the podcast we always
like that and with that let's go
[Music]
philipot welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you very much good to be
here thanks having me I'm very excited
for this podcast because I think I'm not
completely sure but I think this is the
podcast on which the guest and I
disagree most strongly about most of the
important things we'll be talking about
but in a productive way and I really
think I read you have a new book coming
out I read the book and it's fantastic
book very very clear statement of the
case that you want to make in that case
of course is for a pan psychist view of
consciousness so why don't we you know
we had a I had a previous interview with
David Chalmers and so some of the
podcast listeners will have heard that
but not all of them so let's not assume
they know anything why don't you tell us
why there's a problem with consciousness
what it is that we're trying to figure
out when we talk about consciousness
sure well it's it's a big discussion but
I think the core of the problem is that
physical science works with a purely
quantitative vocabulary
whereas consciousness is an essentially
qualitative phenomenon just in the sense
that it involves qualities the redness
of a red experience the smell of coffee
the taste of mint and you can't capture
it seems these qualities in the purely
quantitative vocabulary of physical
science right you can't capture in in
the quantitative language of
neuroscience the redness of a red
experience and so it looks like as long
as your your your description of the
brain is framed in a purely quantitative
vocabulary it seems that you're gonna
miss out these qualities of
consciousness and thereby miss out an
essential component of consciousness so
that that's the way I like to to frame
that the starting point of the
philosophical problem this clash between
the quantities and qualities that
quantities of physical science and the
qualities we know from our own
first-person conscious experience so for
people who do know a little bit about
the issue you're interested here in the
hard problem of consciousness that first
person's subjective experience less so
in the easy problems about how people
behave and how we treat them as
conscious creatures you know how they
perceive the world and things like that
yeah I mean look there's all sorts of
very important things we can do with
with neuroscience and neuroscience is
absolutely essential for making progress
on consciousness I'm a big fan of
neuroscience and you know I try to keep
us up-to-date as I can but I mean I
think essentially he's another way of
putting you know what neuroscience gives
us are correlations between brain
activity and conscious experience so you
can scan people's brains you can ask
them what they're thinking and feeling
and you can get their rich body of
infinite correlation between certain
kinds of brain activity and certain
kinds of conscious experience but that
in itself is not the full story because
if we want a complete theory of
consciousness if we want if you like to
move to solving the hard problem we want
to explain those correlations right we
want to say you know why is it why is it
when you have such and such brain
activity you have feeling of hunger or
whatever and because of the purely
quantitative vocabulary of physical
science it's hard to see how you can
provide any such explanation so yeah so
this is I mean Lister the starting point
is I mean my starting point is we know
that consciousness is real nothing is
more evident than the reality of our
feelings and experiences so we have to
find some way of integrating it into our
scientific story but we can and we can
build correlations and that's fine and
that's important but to give a kind of
deeper explanation we come up against
this difficulty of
the essential qualitative nature of
consciousness and the quantitative
vocabulary of physical science so yeah
that's the challenge yeah and just a
preview a little bit I'm sure we'll get
into this in more detail but my point of
view the point of view of someone like
me which will label the materialist
point of view going forward is that in
some very real sense there is literally
nothing else to say once you've said
what all of the physical stuff in the
universe does right that what we do when
we talk about consciousness or even
feelings of experiences and so forth is
simply come up with a convenient label
for a higher level emergent phenomenon
that is ultimately nothing more than
physical stuff doing things and I think
and this is really where you know a
David I guess and I talked about this a
little bit but I think this is where our
conversation is going to be very very
useful and digging into what exactly is
meant by that distinction like whether
it is or can be a complete explanation
just to say what stuff does yeah and I
mean I I think that's a coherent
position you've just described and you
know I I read some of your most recent
book and yeah I was actually to say that
I was actually struck at how detailed
you go into these these contemporary
philosophical discussions you know
because everything so specialized these
days it's hard to it's hard to you know
learn about I'm jealous of people in the
17th century where you kind of know
everything it's hard to I know and for
they inclined to but yeah but yeah
there's quite a lot of research into
these the details of these contemporary
philosophical discussions and yeah I
think that's a coherent position you
described but I I suppose if you're
going to defend that view so maybe
that's why I probably wouldn't set
things up in the way de Chalmers does I
mean that's been a hugely important
influential way of setting things up but
you might think it's sort of already
assuming what it's trying to prove that
you know neuroscience can just give us
the easy problems then is this hard
whereas you might say I don't see why
there's another problem and but so what
I would say is okay fine
that's a coherent position you've just
described and that would solve the
problem if it made sense but I think you
then have an extra explanatory
obligation right you've got it you know
I I would say maybe you disagree I would
say that we know from our first-person
perspective from our immediate awareness
of our own feelings experiences we know
that consciousness has this qualitative
nature it involves these qualities the
redness of red experience and so on and
I think if you're gonna be a materialist
then you are as an explanation of how
that is accounted for in the terms of
physical science how can you account for
those qualities in the purely
quantitative language of physical
science you know you owe as an
explanation perhaps something like the
explanation of you know the boiling
point of water we can give in terms of
chemistry so I think there's at least an
explanatory obligation for the
materialist before we can say okay that
makes sense yeah I think that's
perfectly fair and I'm biting my tongue
because I want to try to you know give
such an explanation but I will give it
later or at least we will talk about it
later in the podcast let's build our way
up I just wanted to preview for the
audience you know what the stakes were a
little bit
you blame Galileo for people like me
this is a very bold move in the book you
know I mean Galileo is not one of the
people who regularly bash in pop side
discussions so you know maybe give the
audience a clue as to what your beef is
with Galileo sure well you know look I'm
a big fan of Galileo here as well and a
little bit provocative by the way I was
just in Florence in Italy and I don't
know if you've ever been there but there
is a Galileo Museum where they keep his
middle finger the bones of his middle
finger as almost like a religious relic
that's had you al did you go and pay
respects I did I did yeah there was no
burning of
sensor lighting candles or anything like
that but I did have Alice Drakkar as a
podcast guest earlier and she wrote a
whole book called Galileo's middle
finger imagining that Galileo is giving
the middle finger to the rest of the
world I don't think that gesture has the
same meaning in Italy as it does here
but anyway yes we don't actually want to
worship Galileo or anybody else
so go ahead what's the issue of Galilee
so a key moment in the Scientific
Revolution is Galileo's declaration that
mathematics is to be the language of the
new science so the new science is to
have a purely quantitative vocabulary
and so this is a much discussed moment
but what is less focused on what I focus
on in my book is the philosophical work
Galileo had to do to get to that stage
because before Galileo people thought
the physical world was filled with
qualities so there are colors on the
surfaces of objects smells floating
through the air tastes inside food and
this was a challenge for Galileo's
aspiration to give a completely
mathematical description of the physical
world because as we've already discussed
it's hard to see how you can capture
those kind of qualities in a purely
quantitative language how can you
capture in an equation the spiciness of
paprika so Galileo go round this by
proposing a radically new philosophical
theory of reality and according to this
theory those qualities are really out
there in the physical world rather
they're in the consciousness of the
observer which crucially Galileo took to
be outside of the domain of science so
so the redness isn't really on the
surface of the tomato it's on it's in
the consciousness of the person
perceiving the tomato or the spiciness
isn't really in the inside the paprika
it's in the consciousness of the person
eating it so so Galileo as it
stripped the world of its qualities and
after he done that all that were
remained were the purely quantitative
features of matter size shape location
motion things that can be captured in
mathematical geometry so there is this
radical division radical dualism in in
Galileo's picture between the physical
world with its purely quantitative
properties which is the domain of
science and consciousness with its
qualities which is outside of the domain
of science so this is the start of
mathematical physics which has obviously
gone very well but you know crucially
Galileo at least only intended it to be
a partial description of reality right
the whole project was premise on setting
consciousness outside of the domain of
science so I think this is really
important because so it's generally
accepted now the consciousness does pose
a serious scientific problem which is
not always the case but a lot of people
have this following reaction they say
okay you know there's a serious problem
here but you and we just need to do more
neuroscience and we're sorted out and I
think the reason they think that is
because they they look at the great
successes of physical science and
explaining more and more of our universe
and they think you know of course one
day it's it's gonna crack consciousness
but the irony is I would argue that
physical science has been so successful
precisely because it was designed to
ignore consciousness that was the whole
setup
so I think if Galileo were to
time-travel to the present day and hear
about this hard problem of explaining
consciousness in terms of physical
science he'd say of course you can't do
that I designed physical science to deal
with qualities not quantity sorry other
way around
I designed physical science to do with
quantities not qualities so so this what
I'm trying to push here and we're not
really at the stage of arguments it's
sort of narrative that I think I cite as
a philosopher I spend a lot of time on
these fiddly arguments and I think
they're important and maybe we can have
some of those but I think really at the
end of the day it's the big picture that
grabs people yeah the big picture such
as you present in your book you know
that luck
success of science physical science in
particular of course it's going to
explain contest one day but I think
actually there's a different way of
looking at the history of science such
that that that conclusion does not
obviously follow in fact we're probably
led in something of the opposite
direction that's so that's there so
people know in fact yeah your your book
is entitled Galileo's error valuations
for new science and consciousness so I'm
happy to take the pro Galileo point of
view for the rest of the podcast while
you take on the plucky under New Year
well held on you should be a duelist if
you're gonna take the Pro Galileo
position yeah no I'm just I think that I
am what Galileo would have evolved into
that's that's my goal obviously Galileo
lived a long time ago and I don't really
think this is jumping ahead once again
but I don't really think that it's
putting consciousness aside I think that
it is understanding these quantitative
features of the world as ways of talking
about the qualitative features of the
world that's it that's how I would put
it but I mean but Franken just can I
just I'm inclined to think I'm what
Galileo would have evolved into because
I think I think Galileo took physical
science very seriously but he also took
the qualitative reality of consciousness
very seriously and I and I think you
know I think what we're eventually add
to is is a way bringing both together
and so yeah anyway from what I know
about Galileo's personality he would not
have been very happy with a book called
Galileo's error but so good let's I
think we have interesting things to talk
about so let's quickly dispatch what I
think is the least interesting thing
which is the idea of dualism right the
in the old fashioned cartesian idea that
there is a mind distinct from the body
without localization in space or time in
material that somehow talks to it so
you're not in favor of that and neither
am i so let's explain why yes I think
maybe the problems of journalism perhaps
of a more straightforwardly scientific
form so maybe the problems in
materialism or more philosophical in
nature problem
materialist dualism sorry a more
straightforward scientific because so
most duelists although they think the
mind and the brain are distinct they
they also want to hold that they stand
in an intimate causal relationship so
that the you know when light hits the
retina of the eye makes changes in the
brain which will bring about visual
experiences in the soul or vice versa
you know the decisions of the soul to
raise the arm make changes in the brain
and cause the article so so there's an
intimate causal relationship there so
from my point of view if there were an
immaterial entity impacting on the brain
every second of waking life you know I
think that would really show up in on
neuroscience that'd be all sorts of
things happening in the brain that had
no physical explanation it'd be like a
poltergeist was playing with the brain
and I think that's not what we see and
so I think that gives us an ever-growing
sort of inductive argument against
dualism so I mean I I wouldn't want to
completely stop taking dualism seriously
I you know I mind I think there are a
lot of including David Chalmers himself
a lot of interesting work done on this
but to my mind it's it's got a bit of a
hurdle to overcome with those kind of
problems yeah and I completely agree
with everything you said and I said
similar things in the big picture just
again because people might have some
familiarity with the discourse here
there is a distinction drawn between
property duelists and substance duelists
property dualism thinking that there's
truly the the mind is truly another kind
sorry
substance duelists thinking that their
the mind is truly another kind of
substance where and I don't think the
Chalmers is that but property duelists
thinking that there are different kinds
of properties that physical stuff has
physical properties and mental
properties and I think that Chalmers to
the extent that he will allow himself to
be pinned down to any actual position is
probably something closer to that and
maybe you have some sympathies along
those lines too yeah so more this tends
to the property dualist position tends
to go along with
at least in the Dayton David Chalmers
case that commitment to special
psychophysical laws that so if you just
had the laws of physics the thought is
you wouldn't have consciousness we'd all
be zombies but the special psycho
physical laws that are as fundamental as
the laws of physics because those laws
are governing when you have certain
physical states of first they give rise
to consciousness actually I mean let me
say it's interesting saying often when I
am talking to people who consider
themselves materialists they will often
say oh yeah but they often take that to
be the view that the brain produces
consciousness but that's not materialism
right that's dualism if the brain
produces consciousness then
consciousness is this extra stuff so I
actually think at least among sort of
people just thinking about this in
general I think a lot a lot of people
who think themselves in materialist
actually turn out to be property
duelists and when when and when I found
actually when I explained to them what
materialism is there no that's crazy
yeah so you might find it so this is
exactly why philosophy is important
right because people think that they
have a view on something and they
haven't really thought it through and
they talk in sloppy ways and so exactly
you can analyze what's going on and
gonna know your implications are not
quite what are implied by your
assumptions
absolutely so okay good so let's let's
not even spend too much time well we
should pause to give credit to Princess
Elizabeth who was the first to raise
this problem of how the immaterial mind
is supposed to interact with the body
which is now growing up to be called the
interaction problem and are there are
there many actual hardcore substance
duelists hanging around these days in
philosophy departments just a quick word
on Princess Elizabeth it's so she was
expressing worries about the
intelligibility of the relationship
between something physical and something
non-physical I think most people these
days don't worry so much about that it's
more of that would be a mouthful
Safa call worry the worry these days is
more an empirical concern of the sort we
talk about it are there many substitutes
actually I'm not so sure charmers is not
it's not something unsympathetic to
substance dualism actually or definitely
Martina need a room Alan who's in the
university of freiburg in switzerland is
a excellent philosopher and substance to
you list of some kind who but she's
she's you know she's as I say in my book
she's a you know she's a passionate
atheist and she's she just thinks that
the conscious mind is not physical but
it's a natural phenomenon that arises
from the physical and his law governed
and so I think I think actually she's
motivated to substance dualism at least
in part because of thoughts about
identity over time I think some
substance to it maybe we don't want to
get into all that but uh some people are
worried about the wave function of the
universe starts branching into multiple
copies it raises a whole nother
conundrum for those kinds of things
about it in that case yeah so I think
that might be part of motivations as
people yeah alright yeah so brushing
that aside hundreds of years of very
difficult work in philosophy and and
consciousness studies materialism so we
have the idea post Galileo that you know
we're made of these things we can
describe them mathematically that there
is this always this slight footnote to
trying to be a good materialist which is
that what we think the material actually
is changes over time right like Galileo
would have thought it's one thing and
then Adams came along and then quantum
mechanics came along so it's hard even
to pin down what you mean by materialism
or physicalism I will I will grant that
but I think the basic idea is that there
is stuff the stuff obeys the laws of
physics the laws of physics are
impersonal right their equations may be
differential equations may be something
more advanced than that and that's it in
some level we could talk about the
entire world in just those terms
but then there are other higher-level
ways sort of useful effective theories
or whatever you want to call them which
come closer to our fulk
view of the world where there are people
and intentions and thoughts and and so
forth so you're not on board with that
very sensible perspective do you wanna
give us your favorite arguments against
it
oh yeah actually I'm not I don't want to
get lost collectively Russia lost in
definitions just the start but I'm not
sure any of that was inconsistent with
PAL psychism you said actually the I did
say well there is well maybe we'll get
to that it I mean it just I mean the way
I would define materialism actually the
review said that is that fundamental
nature reality can be captured with a
purely quantitative vocabulary involving
just mathematical and causal terms so
that that's at least part of the
definition would you be happy with that
is that well I I'm willing to be happy
with it what when you say it out loud it
strikes me as odd because we're trying
to define materialism and the operative
words in your definition were things
like math and quantitative and that
seems to be a slight sliding of what
you're really aiming at here I mean my
my definition whatever it would be and I
don't claim to have the world's most
perfect definition but stuff obeying the
laws of physics and that's a complete
description like there's no extra
properties over and about physical
properties like this for me the pun
psychist thinks that as well well we'll
get there we'll get there okay but you
don't let's put it this way let's
operationalize it you don't agree with
materialism so tell me why you don't
agree yeah sorry good luck unless
philosophers get lost in hedidn't you
know it's important I'm very hey did you
take yeah okay and so well it really
comes back to the to what we were
talking about earlier so I mean maybe
here's another way of putting it and I
know from your perspective so what is
the job of a theory of reality well what
are we trying to you know
the data for a theory reality and I
guess I think I think you you think that
the data is the data of observation and
experiment right if you've if you've got
a theory that can account for very
roughly maybe you want to know other if
you can account for all of the data of
observation experiment in the most
satisfying elegant simple way you have
job done whereas I think that's that's
not enough there's something there's
another bit of data there's something
else we know to be real namely
consciousness and it's not something we
know through observation and experiment
you know if you look inside someone's
head you can't see that feelings and
experiences so if you know if you're
just aim is just to account for
observation experiment then you never
have any reason to postulate
consciousness I think Daniel Dennett is
wonderfully consistent on this but we do
know that consciousness exists we know
it from our immediate awareness of our
own feelings and experiences in fact I
think Descartes was right that it's the
reality of consciousness is known with
the greatest certainty than anything
about the external world and that's an
extra datum that needs to be accounted
for and we can't assume from the start
that the postulations we made to account
for observation experiment will also
account for this other data in fact you
know in a way it'd be strange if it did
right given that you know what you deal
in the postulations you deal in a
tailored for a specific purpose
explaining observation experiment it
would be kind of a weird crisis if they
also explained these subjective
qualities that were aware of in a
completely different way so that's just
a sort of prime aphasia thing but but
then coming to the crux of it I think
there's there's this good reason to
think that the postulations of physical
science alone cannot account for the
reality of consciousness and again it's
coming back to the issue that
consciousness has a purely as necessary
consciousness has a quality of nature
whereas physical science deals with this
purely
quantitative vocabulary today let me put
the point again in a slightly different
way
you cannot convey so I don't think it's
just that when people have heard about
Dave's hard problem sometimes they think
oh we just haven't got the solution yet
so but I think that's - not to get to
the philosophical core of here of this
the problem is you cannot even capture
the qualities of consciousness in the
language of neuroscience and one way to
see that it if you could if you could
capture what it's like to see read in
the language of neuroscience you could
convey to a blind from birth
neuroscientist what it's like to see
read the quality connotative character
read experience which seems absurd you
know you can only know what it's like to
see read when you actually have a read
experience so I don't think you can even
because of its limited vocabulary I
don't think you can even capture the
qualities of consciousness in the
language of neuroscience so that's a
kind of expressive limitation and I
think that expressive limitation implies
an explanatory limitation you know
because if if you were going to explain
the qualities of consciousness in the
language of neuroscience I it seems to
me you'd have to convey those qualities
in the language of neuroscience and then
explain them in more fundamental
physical terms
if you can't even convey them you can't
even express them then I don't think you
can explain them so I think there are
good in principle reasons to think you
know neuroscience alone physical science
alone because of its quantitative
vocabulary can't give us a complete
account of this phenomenon we know to be
real so it can't be complete it can't be
true yeah and I think the good this is
exactly what I really wanted to dig into
I completely agree that consciousness is
real I've never been very sympathetic to
people who said it was an illusion
I mean Dennett I think he's maybe less
consistent or less clear then the credit
for because like he gets upset when
people say he denies the reality of
consciousness or you know but he does
sometimes he knew
and I'm not sure where to land but I
don't think it's an illusion I think
it's a higher level of emergent
phenomena I think it's a very different
thing so I'm torn let me let me I'll
give you two choices I want to talk
about zombies I want to talk about
intrinsic natures which do you think
make sense to talk about first
let's go at least before yeah before
answering because I want to get into the
details of what he just said but a nice
little you know thought experiment on
the table would be useful so give me
your version of the other zombie
argument yeah I mean I don't tend to you
prefer some B's rather than Mary I think
you know Mary is easy me I mean even
even Frank Jackson who invented Mary
gave up on her eventually so I think I'm
on Form there so I don't know tell us
about Mary the color scientist yeah I
think I preferred Mary in some way I
seems to always get gets very technical
a zombie argument I think and right so
Mary is sorry I just have got it on the
table I think that zombies are the
world's best argument against pain
psychism which side I do want to talk
about at some point okay talk about
makers so I think it's a way of it's
really just a way of explicating and
giving further to support to what I've
already been talking about so Mary is
this genius color scientist who knows
everything neuroscience can teach you
about color experience so you know the
wavelengths hitting the eyes the changes
that makes in the brain how it gives
rise to various forms of behavior but
for some reason that's never explained
she's been raised in a black and white
room right I think that the way the
exposition is not very good okay I think
in a way we could have just had a
colorblind neuroscientist or something
does this guy not know be who's uh who's
a color expert who can only see black
and white and shades of gray and has
written some interesting stuff from his
own position anyway right anyway so
let's come back to Mary so so she knows
everything there is to know everything
neuro sorry I should say everything new
Oh science can teach you about color
experience and then one day but she's
never actually seen colors cuz of this
black of my room and one day again not
explained she's liberated from a black
and white room and she sees colors for
the first time so the proponent large
argument says at this point she learned
something new she learns what it's like
to see color one problem with this is so
that's the story and people because a
story so simple I think people are often
too quick to think they've got the
argument but so here's the argument the
knowledge argument that's based on this
story the thought is if materialism is
true then in principle neuroscience
ought to be able to give us a complete
story of the essential nature of color
experience a complete account of what's
going on Mary by stipulation knows that
so there ought to be nothing more she
can learn about the nature of color
experience she knows it all as IG I give
in my book is you know if you've got the
complete final theory of black holes
right you ought to be able to in order
to be the case that you can't learn
anything new any new essential features
of black holes because you've got the
complete file of theory so it ought to
be if materialism is true there's
nothing more let Mary can learn and yet
when she comes out of her room she does
gain some new information about the
essential nature of color experience she
learns what it's like to see color and
this is information that couldn't be got
from the neuroscience and so and so in
some sense the neuro scientific account
must have been incomplete because
there's information about color
experience that goes beyond what the
neuroscience can provide and and then so
just to link it back to what I've been
talking about a lot already
what is that information what does she
learn she learns about the qualitative
character of colors the redness of a red
experience that's what I can generously
blind neuroscientist no matter how much
neuroscience they've learned
we'll never know about so there's
there's information there that goes
beyond what neuroscience can capture
that's there so there's a bit
long-winded no no this is good
so here's what I would say about that
I mean let me I have a long thing to say
let me just say the short thing if Mary
knows everything about the neuroscience
of color that is to say what exactly
happens in a human brain when a human
being looks at something that is red
clearly that is different from
experiencing red no one argues with that
right and so the analogy to me is if I
give you all the laws of particle
physics and atomic physics and gravity
and so forth and you know them and you
have the equations in front of you and I
say okay tell me about the lifecycle of
a star well that's in principle you
could figure it out in practice there's
enormous amount of work to do in
principle Mary could say okay all I need
to do is to have my neurons fire in the
following way which are the ways that
they fire if I were seeing red so I will
hook myself up to the correct electro
stimulator machine and I will make those
neurons fire in the right way and I will
experience the experience of red and I
don't see anything in there that gets in
the way of being a materialist yeah but
if you learning the theory of black
holes so yeah look I completely agree I
think this is I think there's a little
bit of it
people say always think the argument is
about I've heard but the change in
memory you know that the oh how come she
can't she knows all the neurons how come
she can't experience red that's that's
not the argument of course of course you
know the materialism the materialist
does not have to deal that's not a
problem to materialist but like let
notice the dis analogy right to know the
relevant facts about black holes are you
you picked a complicated example but let
me start again
to know all the facts about black holes
you don't have to become a black hole
right it ought to be the case that you
can know a
I think there is to know about color
experience from the neuroscience and
terrorism stroke not saying you ought to
be able to experience colors no that's
not the point you ought to be able to
know all the facts from the neuroscience
and you've just conceded that you can't
do that you have to she has to have
changes in any or ons why why does she
have to do that if materialism is true
if materialism is true all the
information should be there in the
neuroscience and she's got it yeah you
don't have to turn yourself into a black
hole to learn the theory of black holes
why do you have to make changes to your
brain to know the full theory of what
color experience is yeah I mean I think
it's because you've set up the question
in a certain way like it do you you need
to be a black hole to know what it is
like to be a black hole and of course
the difference which which I which I
completely agree with is that black
holes don't have self-awareness or
thoughts or anything like that so you
can argue that there isn't anything that
it's like to be a black hole
I concede that there is something it is
like to be a person but that's because
we have the capacity to hold in our
brains representations of ourselves and
you know attitudes towards things and
therefore it's that I would say that's
not a very good analogy there is
something that that is different even if
you're a materialist do you think this
information marry in a black and white
room do you think there's information
about the nature of color experience she
doesn't have in principle no but but we
get them I'm conceding that it is
different to know a bunch of facts about
neuroscience and to experience something
I just think that from knowing those
facts about neuroscience you can
experience something without actually
experiencing it you can make your brain
do the things that it would do if you
were experiencing it and that would be
the same as actually experiencing
because all that's happening is things
that are happening in your neurons so I
think there's two different things going
on here one is a question of complexity
that the in principle question and that
was your life cycle of a star or what
was it that the light of the star yeah
and this is something Dennard often
presses
and I think it's a little bit of a red
herring it's maybe an unfortunate
consequence of the way Jackson set up
the thought experiment he said you know
she knows everything physical you know
every quark in every but I don't think
you need to set it up like that
presumably you know the futures
neuroscientific theory is just gonna be
you know a natural extension of what we
have today so I I don't think it's
impossible to think a normal human being
could know that so I don't think so I
think we can set on one side these
worries about in principle knowing the
point is as you accept to do some
information here that you have to make
changes to your brain to get that
information and I'm suggesting if
materialism is true that's weird why
would you have to make changes to your
brain to get the information so we're
all let me put it we're all agreeing
that you have to make changes to have
the experience but I suppose the way
why'd you have to have the experience to
get the information Yeah right
that doesn't seem even a little bit
surprising to me like I could tell you
in gruesome detail the correct way to
shoot a free-throw in basketball and you
can sit at your desk and you can study
everything there is to know about
shooting a free day and if you've never
shot a free-throw before you're not
gonna be very good at it because the way
that we learn things through our eyes
and our ears and recording information
is just different than our how our body
reacts to these things okay it's
surprising as a materialist okay good
good do not now what you know what
you're presenting I think is what's
known as the ability hypothesis response
right which is which originally by
what's-his-name Nemiroff Leonard
Nemiroff was it and but it was defended
by David Lewis who's quite a big figure
and lawsuit philosophy generally so
anyway the view is here so I keep trying
to press on new information as
information Mary can't get in their
black room but what what Lewis says is a
number of she knows she doesn't gain new
information she gains new know-how new
abilities that's what she learns she
learns how to
you imagine read categorize things as
read
remember read and so on so she gains you
know how now that now that's that would
that's a perfectly good response because
then yeah
neuroscience gives you all the
information she just gained some new
abilities that that's not a problem for
materialism okay so I think there were a
couple of problems with this response do
you want a technical one or an intuitive
one give us both give us whatever you
Ireland I'll let you decide technical is
fine we're not where we have an hour
long here you know it's funny time the
technical one is it seems you can put
these sentences about what it's like to
see read into deductive syllogisms so
you could say Mary could say if this is
what it's like for me to see read then
this is what it's like for Billy to see
read this is what it's like for me to
see read therefore it is what it's like
for Billy to see read so there's a valid
truth preserving argument there now
forget whether the premises are true or
false but it's see that seems to show
that the these what it's like no
sentences are truth claims and the
problem with the ability hypothesis is
it it doesn't have any account of that
it just talks about abilities but
abilities are not the same as truth
claims so that's the sort of well this
is actually I mean maybe maybe you'll be
helpful to talk a little bit about
intrinsic natures which I mentioned
before and you talked about in the book
because I think that this is the
fundamental underlying issue that we
have that you know Galileo and I have
with with you in pants like it's the
idea that Ella layers on my side well
you know I didn't say invade an error so
you know that you guys you built your
house you got to live in it I'll stop
interrupt in there I think yeah so well
I mean why don't you say I shouldn't put
words in your mouth why don't you tell
us what you mean by the idea that
physics doesn't tell a fillip physics
tells us what things do but it doesn't
tell us about their turns intrinsic
natures and this is also it goes back to
Bertrand Russell
right and yeah I I actually learned from
your book that Russell was one of the
one of the big names in Penn psychism I
didn't know that yeah well actually
Russell as I put in some of the
footnotes didn't quite have a pun
psychist interpretation of it but he
didn't quite get yeah it's as close as
dammit just because he had some funny
terminological issues but anyway yes so
I think actually there's been a real
resurgence of interest in pun psychism
in academic philosophy in the last eight
to ten years it's gone from being
laughed at insofar as it was thought of
at all to being taken quite seriously
and I think this is largely due to the
rediscovery of this work important work
from the 1920s by Arthur Eddington
scientist and Bertrand Russell so I'm
inclined to think these guys did in the
1920s for the science of consciousness
what Darwin did for the science of life
in the nineteenth century and it's sort
of a tragedy of history that it got kind
of forgotten about and okay so the
starting point is as you were just
alluding to that physics tells us a lot
less than you might think about the
nature of physical reality so in the
public mind physics is giving us this
complete story of the nature of space
and time and matter but what Brooke
Russell and Eddington realize is
actually upon reflection it turns out
that physical science is confined to
telling us about the behavior of matter
about what it does so physics talks
about mass and charge you know we
characterize mass in terms of
gravitational attraction resistance to
acceleration charge is characterized in
terms of traction and repulsion this all
concerns what particles or fields do
right physics is completely silent on
what philosophers like to call the
intrinsic nature of a physical entity
how it is in and of itself independently
of its behavior and so so this is
sometimes called the problem of
intrinsic natures it looks like there's
this huge hole in our scientific story
of the universe and then so what just
that link to consciousness very briefly
I think the genius of Rasul and
Eddington was to bring together two
problems that on the face of it have
nothing much to do with each other the
problem of consciousness and the problem
of intrinsic natures so the problem of
consciousness is roughly the need to
find a place for consciousness in our
scientific story the problem of
intrinsic natures is that we have this
huge hole in our scientific story of the
universe so the unified solution is put
consciousness in the hole right through
we look at for a place we've got justice
we've got this big hole but
consciousness you know so the resulting
theory is a kind of pun psychism you you
did just matter or just physical stuff
fields maybe there's nothing spiritual
or supernatural but physical reality can
be described as it were from two
perspectives physical science describes
it as it were from the outside tells us
rich information about its behavior but
as it were from the inside its intrinsic
nature is constituted of forms of
consciousness so this is a beautifully
simple elegant unified way of
integrating consciousness into our
scientific worldview and in contrast
dualism it's consistent with everything
we know empirically so from my
perspective just final sentence we've
got this challenge how do we bring
together what we know empirically about
the physical world from natural science
and what we know this qualitative
reality we know from our immediate
wellness of consciousness this gives us
a way of bringing it together in a way
that's entirely consistent with both
yeah so that's that's that's the big
picture of the view I try to defend yeah
and I think the reason why I wanted to
bring that up right now is because it is
the underlying to me the underlying
source of all of our other disagreements
and in some sense like I totally would
buy the idea that
you've told me what the stuff does
you're done there isn't anything else
there's no such thing as the intrinsic
nature of stuff and I think maybe you
know maybe this is where you can educate
me I think that reflects back onto our
discussion about Mary the whether or not
or just more generally what it is like
to be something I think what it is like
to be something what is like to
experience read ultimately is a
description of certain things going on
in our neurons and our bodies and I
don't have a strong opinion about
whether or not there are truth claims
associated with that that are sort of
inter mind like you know the old
question of you know whether that red I
see is the same as the red you see I'm
not sure whether that has a sensible
explanation but I do think that when I
say I'm experiencing red that not only
correlates exactly with certain neurons
doing something in my brain but is just
a way of saying that certain neurons are
doing something in my brain so I think
that that is the same as the intrinsic
nature disagreement so let me just say
one thing really that I wouldn't I think
you do have a coherent position and I
wouldn't describe it as denying the
reality consciousness I think you you
had these dialogues in your book of sort
of people think of denying consciousness
and maybe some of my auntie physicalist
comrades would say that but uh IIIi if
that view works out I think it's it's
clearly accepting the reality of
consciousness you know I just don't
think it's ultimately coherent but
that's just a brief put I'm not inclined
to agree that this comes down to whether
we need intrinsic natures you know to my
mind that's as distinct and you know
more contentious view I can imagine
being persuaded we could look at some of
the arguments if you wanna as to why we
need to postulate intrinsic natures at
all but I can imagine being persuaded
that sure we don't need there's a
coherent picture the world and
there's no intrinsic natures and so I on
this kind of view things are just doings
rather than beings you know once you've
said what it does you said everything
but I still think I would I would think
well there's this qualitative reality
what about these qualities we need some
account of them and I haven't yet heard
an explanation in term in physical
science terms so I and I would push
these arguments that there are in
principle reasons to thinking that can't
be done so I guess I would be inclined
to think these are these are distinct
issues I mean I guess what we're we're
came unclear to me is when you bring up
the qualitative features the qualitative
experiences and so forth that I mean
that maybe I'm getting it's wrong but it
kind of at least reminds me resonates
with the idea that there is something
over and above what the things are doing
and maybe it's not intrinsic nature yes
okay good word above what things are
doing so maybe put it like this I guess
I think there are two reasons why we
need intrinsic natures one I'm not sure
it's intelligible to have a picture of
the world without them forget about
consciousness and we could get into a
zygotes maybe or not but the other is
there is this reality we know about and
it's hard and it's hard to see how you
can account for it in causal structural
terms but that's a step that's in a way
there's two steps to that argument right
one is there is this datum we need to
account for and secondly it's to my mind
there are good arguments why it can't be
accounted for in causal structural terms
so I suppose there yeah you get the
implication that it's a kind of
intrinsic nature yeah yeah maybe that's
right but it's but it maybe it is worth
I want to give you a chance to give the
positive case an explanation for
or pan psychism which we've kind of only
alluded to so far but I think because I
do think that this kind of divergence is
at the heart of all of our divergences
maybe it is worth saying some words
about why you think that intrinsic
natures really are necessary if I if I
knew all of the mathematical structures
and causal relationships among the
physical stuff of the universe and could
say what everything did there would
still be something lacking so I don't
think these are not lacking once that
happens and you do tell me tell us why
ok let's get into that argument but I
think I've just clarified to myself
what's going on so I mean I think it's
you seem to be saying that they could I
believe in intrinsic natures because I
think consciousness is irreducible not
the other way around right so it's not
like I start up saying other must be
these intrinsic natures it's because of
consciousness
but but also I do think there must be
insurance in natures so so maybe we
maybe maybe we could get in fact so I
guess people Leppa logically separate
but they're in the same spirit that's
all I was right right those two facts
yeah that's interesting so it might be
something I might have to think so
people are defending this this Russell
Eddington picture going right back to
Russell have tried to defend this this
kind of argument to the conclusion that
a world without entrance in HS is just
unintelligible you know I go a little
bit back and forward on these arguments
I have to say I'm not I'm not uh I'm not
a hundred percent committed but the
thought is without intrinsic nature's
everything ends up being defined in
terms of everything else and you end up
in a kind of vicious circle so I have an
appendix to one of the chapters of my
book ohms so the studies you know you
start off saying what's mass then you
say you know let's just keep things
simple let's ignore general relativity
and you either say oh it's it's you know
it causes gravitational attraction they
say and I said ok whoa
what's what's attraction and he said
well it's you know it's when I don't
know the distance between bodies is
decrease and you say well what's
distance and then you
get another bunch of equations that
explicate distance in terms of other
physical properties like mass and charge
and you quickly find yourself back in a
circle and without any way of getting an
independent grip on any of these
properties it looks like these
definitions just don't get off the
ground so the analogy I give in the book
is suppose I've got three match boxes
and I say there's this in the first one
there's a splurge and the second one is
obliged and the third one is acreage and
you say what's a blurred nice no that's
easy it's sir the flood is something
that makes splurges okay well I don't
know what that means it'll end up with a
splurge is what's a splurge and I says
splurge is the thing that makes cages
and you say well I don't know what that
means either to learn over to cages and
I say well it's the thing that makes
splurges and you don't know what the
hell is in the match boxes so I sort of
think that's actually how and this is
how Russell thought this is actually our
physics works it everything's in two
defined and so without a kind of
independent grip we don't really get an
understanding of what any of these
things are so now that was the kind of
argument he pressed what do you reckon
yeah I will just very quickly say why I
did not find that argument convincing
but I'm glad that it's out there I agree
that's an individual term like mass
can't be defined without talking about
other things there's absolutely
interconnectedness but rather than sir
excuse me
rather than circularity I would just say
one defines an entire formal system no
space-time is a four dimensional
manifold we'll Orencia metric blah blah
blah and there's a whole bunch of
individually very well-defined parts of
that formal system and then one maps it
on to the data of our experience and
says we've explained the world I don't
think it's circular I do think it's
interconnected so I'm not convinced
there you go but what if I say you know
what does it feel tell me what to feel
this field there's a section of a fiber
bundle I mean the these are there is a
mathematical formalism and I can
pinpoint individual parts of it so I
don't care you talk about the intrinsic
nature of them that's that's my escape
hatch right if I don't care about what
it really is if I just
about where it is in the math that I'm
done but I mean even if you're taking
yeah so that this depends there are a
couple of different issues here what one
is there are two subtly related views I
mean I guess what you're defending a
kind of what's come tactical antics
structuralism that in some sense it's
just structure but there are two closely
related views here one is a pure
structuralism where there's just what
can be captured mathematically another
is causal structuralism which is a
little bit more modest it's what can be
captured with mathematics and causal
terms and on that view way we ultimately
define the nature of things in terms of
what they do
would you say that you were going to the
former or the latter I think of the
former yeah and that right hander
proposal terms at fundamental ontology
right right so so the world can be just
entirely captured in mathematical
language yeah so there is the world and
there is a mathematical formal system
and there's a nice and Worf ISM between
them and take you know it's all
complicated and philosophy is necessary
because there's also our Volk experience
of the world which is like a third thing
that we have to map onto both of those
in interesting ways but it's it's a
coherent set of interconnections not a
circular argument that's that's the last
thing okay well I think in that case
maybe we could just sympathetic to kind
of humanely I think maybe we've been
talking slightly across purposes because
that argument is is more an attack on
people who want to take causation as a
fundamental feature and we don't define
the nature of saying electron in terms
of what it does yeah I think that
problem goes away a little bit if you
just think and in fact it has been a
reply to there was a volume of essays on
on this this form of pun psychism and a
listen a who's it's lost very good
philosopher of physics is replying and
exists in exactly these ways arguing
that that you know we could just have
the wavefunction or something in a key
expressed in
a mathematical language just
parenthetically I am the author of an
idea called mad dog Eveready anism we're
literally all that exists is a vector in
a giant hilbert space representing the
universe and a Hamiltonian that tells us
how it evolves and everything else
space-time matter particle fields are
just particular human constructions to
conveniently talk about what that wave
function does over time sure yeah so so
so I guess at that point what what I
would say is okay maybe are you familiar
with Newman's problem have you know that
I've heard of it but I couldn't explain
it so why don't you explain it yes well
the problem is I can't remember the
details either but yeah okay so to the I
mean the way I've thought about these
things is the the the causal
structuralism faces this regress problem
and the more pure structuralism faces
Newman's problem but it's a while since
I've I've looked at the details new
table so I don't think I'd be able to
defend that but let's say let's say you
persuade me that that that the mad dog
Everette anism you just described is
describes a possible reality and that
that theory can account for data all the
date of observation experiments then I
then I take fine that's that's fair
enough but I'd say well look there's
this other datum well how do you account
for this of course the qualitative
reality of consciousness and and then
we'd be back to the knowledge argument
we'd be back to to my claim that you
can't account for that in a purely
quantitative vocabulary so so in a way
look I just think the reality of
consciousness is a datum in its own
right over and above the data of
experiments and observation so if you've
got a theory that can account for all
the date of observation experiments but
you can't account for this then your
theory doesn't work and you said I mean
I guess you've said okay
course you're not gonna want to deny
consciousness but you know in all of the
cases that's an option right that's if
you know that there are lots of
phenomena that are difficult to fit into
our scientific worldview
you know facts about value I know you're
interested in facts about freewill
abstract objects solidity in some sense
maybe our folk notion of solidity or our
folk notions of time in all of these
cases it's at least an option to either
deny the phenomenon or revise our
understanding of it you know maybe there
aren't really facts about value maybe
we're not really free in the way we
think we are
maybe time isn't how we thought it was
but I think with consciousness it's a
reality that we know in such a direct
way that I don't think it's an option to
either deny it or revise it so I think
it's it has a very special place in our
methodology and because of that one
needs to be hesitant about whether the
stuff we postulated to account for
observation experiments can also account
to this and I haven't heard from you yet
a story about how that's done and you've
said that it can do it but you haven't
told me how it does it well I don't
think we've done it yet so there you go
I'm very happy to admit that but I my
the extent to which I'm impressed with
materialism is just so vast that of
course consciousness being involved with
the most complicated structures we know
of in the universe will be the last
thing that science successfully explains
not because he inquires something
separate just because it's hard you know
that's why it's hard but anyway I think
we could get stuck here rather I would I
want you to really know here is the
chance sure
I mean I think that's where it comes
back to the Galileo point precisely
maybe let's not get it you know it's
that yeah science is is so impressive
but it's impressive at a very limited
task describing the behavior of matter
roughly mathematical models that capture
it was never in the business
of accounting for subject these
subjective qualities that were
immediately aware of that's never what
it's been doing so like to say oh it's
it's been good at this one thing so it's
gonna be good at this other thing I just
think there's something confuse going on
there I mean I have this analogy in my
book that when I was first my first year
as a lecturer the head of department
very kindly let me off administration
and I was pretty good at the other
aspects of the job was pretty good at
teaching pretty good at research the
fact that I was good at teaching in
research doesn't give you any reason to
think I'm gonna be good at admin right
so similarly the fact that the fact that
physics has been really good physical
science more generally really good at
these mathematical models to describe
behavior why does that give you any
reason to think it's gonna be able to
capture these subjective qualities that
were immediately aware of and anyway
yeah sorry no no actually that's
wonderful I'm glad you said that let me
respond to it and we'll see whether or
not we can be strained ourselves from
going okay I think that's crucially
important because when you have
something like consciousness it's like
when you have any part of scientific
explanation or you know broader
philosophical explanation that isn't
finished yet right we admit that we
don't have the full understanding none
of us does and therefore as individual
scholars and researchers we make bets we
have credence --is about what the is the
most likely future path of progress
right and I talked about this in my
upcoming book I kind of breezed through
it in the big picture but in something
deeply hidden when I'm talking about
quantum mechanics I think that it helps
illuminate why some people are cheerful
Eveready ins and some people find it to
be abhorrent and therefore go for hidden
variables or something like that and
it's because we we we do have the world
of our experience our you know sort of
objective data collecting experience and
our subjective inner experience let's
lump it all into one thing and we
haven't yet fully explained it and which
is more likely among the following two
options number one is an explanation
that is more or less close to the
phenomena that we're observing like the
structures within the explanation
there's
lot of them and it's kind of a
complicated you know set of things going
on but the map between those structures
and what we experience and what we see
is very clear and crisp and easy that
would be a hidden variable approach to
quantum mechanics where of course
there's particles and waves in the
double slit experiment because there's
particles and ways in my ontology or the
other option is you have an extremely
beautiful austere simple powerful
underlying formalism but the road from
there to explaining the world of our
experience is long and fraught with
peril
right that's the Eveready in perspective
where you know like I said you just have
one vector in a big hilbert space and
you have a lot of work to do to say why
the world looks like three-dimensional
space plus time with fields and all that
stuff and either one of those options is
very much on the table and there is a
matter of taste or style that comes into
saying oh I'm pretty sure it's this one
right and I think it likewise for
consciousness like of course we have not
explained consciousness in any
convincing way as materialists but I
have no trouble believing that it will
eventually happen because materialism is
so beautiful and elegant and so powerful
and and I get even if I don't agree with
the perspective that says I just don't
see how we'll ever get here from there
and you know I think that's a perfectly
valid perspective and we'll I think the
progress will be made and we'll figure
it out and you think what do you think
when we when we get the final physical
explanation it will be able to convey to
a congenitally blind neuroscientist what
it's like to see red by going in and
manipulating their brain yes not by
talking to them so just like I can't
teach some I can't teach someone to be a
good free-throw shooter by talking to
them either okay let me this is not a
diss this is not getting back to it but
I mean I completely agree with that
whole thing you've just said with every
phenomena every phenomenon sorry
except consciousness because I think
every other phenomenon is you know
capturing the causal structure of the
but this is we don't know about it in
that way we know about it in a very
different way and so I think that gives
us the entitlement to give a different
credence to it because you know we have
a very different APIs to melodical
relationship with it I think we
apprehend its reality directly and we
know something about its reality
directly I think you know when I attend
to the qualities in my experience I know
something about their nature I don't
have that with tables you know if I had
that with tables if I could magically
know something about their nature then
maybe you know that would give me less
credence the physical science can
explain it but I don't have that it's
just but with consciousness like I think
I have some direct access to its nature
and so that's why I think I can have
very different credence in the
possibility of physics so I ended up I
ended up coming back to the argument I
said I wouldn't I know I'm biting my
tongue I have things to say what I
really want to say is right
tell us what pain psychism actually says
let's give us a sales pitch you're at a
there's you're a used car dealership and
it's your used consciousness theory
dealership and someone's wandered onto
the lot and you would like to sell them
this pen psychist
vehicle that you've been trying to move
for a long time what is your sales pitch
well I mean I think in a in a way I've
already described it that this that
there's just matter
there's just what physical science
describes it describes but let me
emphasize actually how Nandu listed is
because often when people hear about
punt cycles and they think and I think
actually you said this a little bit in
your book actually but you think it's
well the the electron has its physical
properties like mass charge and spin and
it also has these consciousness
properties and you rightfully said you
know that that ought to show up in our
in our physics you know there's these
extra properties that's not the view
right the view is mass spin and charge
of themselves forms of consciousness
right so physics tells us what mass been
in charge do but it doesn't tell us what
they are what those what those
properties are and so so it's a rad
lately non-dualistic accountant by the
very way it's set up it's gonna be
completely consistent with what with
what we know scientifically how would I
sell it mean let me just say can I say
just briefly how I think about the
science of consciousness actually could
you could you do me a favor and tell the
very charming story that you told in the
book of your conversion experience oh no
my wife told me to take that out because
to cringey no but you know it's a it's
you have to it's part of being a good
sales pitch you don't have to tell if
you don't want to but it's been through
various phases have always been obsessed
by the problem of consciousness as far
back as I can remember and you know what
thought I was in maturity materialist I
was the materialist yeah yeah and claim
to know what it's like to be a material
I guess I I eventually came to the point
of view that somewhat Donati in point of
view that if you're a materialist she
you that's incompatible with the reality
of the qualitative reality of
consciousness and defended that for a
while while sort of feeling that like I
was living in bad faith that I was sort
of not really believing and yeah just
just one night and just certain vivid
experiences got to me and I just decided
this can't go on anymore and I mean
ityou but actually at that point I was
taught as a philosophy undergraduate the
only two options and materialism and
dualism and I thought oh these are
hopeless and I was very disillusioned
and I wrote my end of year undergraduate
dissertation on how the problem of
consciousness can't be resolved and I
went often did something else and then I
disc you know plan psychism was not
taught those day and I discovered there
is this elegant middle way that does
accept the reality of consciousness but
is completely consistent with our
empirical knowledge of the world so I
think that was the you say something
like mass charge and spin are properties
of consciousness was that is that no
they are made they are forms of
consciousness forms of conscious
okay I mean what I want to say is what
in the world does that mean well well I
think I think nothing is so-so
some people think you know there's a
mystery of what a consciousness is I
don't I don't think that's a mystery I
think you know what nothing is more
obvious than you know what a feeling you
know what a feeling of pain is when you
have it you know that you know that the
mystery is how consciousness fits into
our theory of the world so you know
human consciousness is very rich and
complex consciousness of horses less so
mice less so you know we keep getting
simpler and simpler forms of inorganic
life maybe at some point the lights
switch off we have no consciousness at
all but it seems at least coherent that
as we get simpler and simpler forms of
matter you have simpler and simpler
forms of consciousness such as when you
get to the bottom let's just assume for
the sake of simplicity of particle
ontology which depends like Couture
don't necessarily have to commit to
although you know you often talk about
that one often talks that wait for
things and fifty an electron has an
unimaginably simple form of experience
so you know we can't you can imagine
something so simple so it seems to me a
coherent view you might think it's crazy
but it seems to realistic coherent view
moreover I think there's reason to take
it seriously because we know that
consciousness is real we have to fit it
into reality somehow if you think
materialism and dualism have got such
deep problems that they're not really
gonna make it happen then this gives us
a way of doing it that avoids all the
problems and it feels a bit weird I
guess that well yeah no I mean weird
obviously we're gonna have to accept it
for you if we talk about any of these
things the weird is okay but I really
want to get a better if I were if I were
very cynical here be my problem I have
an electron I have equations for what it
does it has a mass charge and spin I
have the Dirac equation I have quantum
field theory I can tell you exactly what
it will do
as the materialist physicist I'm tempted
to say I'm done I know what the electron
is and and how it behaves and you want
to say and it has some very very
primitive limited form of conscious
experience is that fair but they depends
on you might and that's not a further
property I'm saying you tell me what
mass does yeah but you haven't tell me
what it is that's the that's right
there's something I haven't told you yet
I guess maybe I put a - there's
something extra that I haven't yet told
you sure and but that something extra I
haven't yet told you has no mathematical
description yeah that's right and it
also has does it have causal influences
on the behavior of anything yeah the
thought is you've been telling me this
cool story about what mass does and then
the pants like is view is mass is a form
of consciousness so it's actually it's
it's this form of consciousness that's
been doing all the stuff you've been
talking about that I mean it's not like
this is the consciousness and then
there's something else there's just the
forms of consciousness and you've been
telling me what they do so it's like you
know you I don't know you you hear
someone banging in the apartment
downstairs and something's you know
something's making this noise but you
don't know what it is and then you
discover it's an elephant I don't know
so see you you physicists study what
these properties do but on this view
you're not saying what they are that's
the yeah but maybe is maybe I'm not
being this exactly right is so mass is a
form of consciousness yeah
is that because everything is a form of
consciousness or these physical
properties are forms of consciousness is
the wave function of the universe a form
of consciousness yes so look it depends
on what you think the fundamental
ontology is that so the plants like is
view is whatever your fundamental
physical story is that will give you
some structure
but then you've got a rascal what
realizes that structure and what
realizes that structure are forms of
consciousness so if you have a particle
based on telogen these particles will
have intrinsic if you've got a wave yes
sorry if you've got a wave function
ontology then you have to think about
that the wave function has instead
trinsic nature as consciousness
involving so that was just asking does
everything have this is this is part of
the plants likest
view that everything has an aspect of
consciousness everything at the
fundamental level so the plants like is
you need not hold it like rocks and
socks and you know beds are conscious
not every arbitrary collection of things
as conscious but everything has
components or its most basic parts of
conscious or or the or the physical
reality that underlies it at least has a
consciousness involving nature that's
the view but but okay but I'm just
trying to get straight i as a
materialist who doesn't use those words
have a theory of what does happen in the
world and your theory of what does
happen in the world your theory as a
pants I Kissed need not be any different
from mine right right exactly that's the
that's that's taken to be the benefit of
the view right we we don't want our
theory of consciousness to get in the
way of physics right yeah right but okay
so this is where you know I think that
the zombie thought experiment is
actually helpful because if it's true
that there's different versions of the
zombie thought experiment so let me just
always conditional eyes on various
assumptions here if it's true that given
the atoms and particles and forces in me
including in my brain and my neurons and
so forth
I could in principle be laplace's demon
and solved the laws of physics and say
exactly what I would do modulo quantum
uncertainty and so forth
and that would include things like
showing me something red and me saying
oh yes that is red I am experiencing red
and there and all that goes through
perfectly well within both of our
different
views of the world and then I'm not
quite sure what is added by the pan
psychist perspective in other words let
me very short version of that so if I
the zombie is David Chalmers his idea of
you know a physical thing that acts
exactly like things in the real world
the physical yeah a collection of atoms
and so forth but that does not have
consciousness and my point is if it
exacts if it acts exactly the same that
includes when you ask it do you have
consciousness are you experiencing
things it says yes and if you ask it are
you lying it says no so clearly it
honestly thinks it's conscious but it's
not by hypothesis yeah so it by that
therefore none of us knows that we're
not a zombie because zombies think that
they're conscious just like we do and
therefore you've really added nothing
okay this sounds a little bit different
to what you said the first time I mean
the first time you see we say well just
brutally what's the difference between a
world it's physically identical and
lacks consciousness in one that's I mean
I don't know how to say we're clear but
there in the sense that when we describe
physical reality we use these
quantitative concepts when we describe
consciousness we use these qualitative
concepts we talk about you know colors
and smells and the qualitative character
it seems to perfectly coherent to
hypothesize that you might have one
without the other
but but coming to your you know a second
argument as I'm understanding it what
doesn't this imply none of us would know
we were conscious I mean there there are
tricky issues here actually just as a
preliminary thought about the
relationship between thought and
consciousness so the dominant view in my
philosophical tradition has been that
thought has nothing to do with
consciousness and you can see this
because the dominant theories of thought
in the 20th century such as Jerry Fodor
or Donald Davidson or Dennett have
absolutely nothing to say about
consciousness so they think you can give
a complete account of
thought without talking about
consciousness and so on that view or
about computation and so forth yeah
there's some kind of functional behavior
of facts or yeah very very rough very
very broadly speaking so on that viewer
zombie what would have thoughts and
would think it's conscious as he say but
I mean I'm actually one of a growing
minority of philosophers you think
actually thought is a kind of
consciousness
and if that's true then the zombie
wouldn't have any thoughts at all so
that's I mean that's one way you can go
with this but maybe that's getting into
slightly contentious territory but I
mean the other thing to say is yeah the
zombie behaves in all the same ways but
I don't know about my consciousness it's
not the case that I know about my
consciousness by observing myself I know
about it because I'm immediately aware
of my own experiences but then that's
what a zombie would say it would say
that but it's it's not true of the
zombie by stipulation it doesn't have
this what justifies what grounds my
knowledge of consciousness is my
immediate awareness of my own pain and
by stipulation that's what does um be
lacks yeah no I think both of our
positions are out there that's all I
ever asked for in the podcast is that
people understand but both sides right
so let's let's uh be a little bit more
you know future oriented and and
proactive how do you think what do you
think of the prospects for consciousness
and pants.i cos I mean you try to end
the book on an uplifting note and I
think it's an interesting perspective to
conclude with sure so I think you know
this views been getting taken much more
seriously in academic philosophy and you
know part of the reason I wrote this
book so I've written an academic book
consciousness and fundamental reality
which is kind of reasonably well known
bringing together a lot of this recent
literature has been a huge amount
published on this view but you know I
really want to get it out to a broader
audience because it's not really a
complete view this Russell Addington
view it's a
it's a framework and it will take you
know decades or centuries of
interdisciplinary labor to fill in the
details you know just as Darwin's
principle of natural selection is you
know it is a basic framework for
understanding how life evolves but then
it takes you know a century to get to
DNA so so really I think you know this
is gonna be you know I just think people
are not naturally conservative it's it's
hard to persuade people with arguments
but I just think you know we need to get
on with this if enough people are on
board with trying to do this and there's
you know there's all very kind of very
interesting work going on well let me
just say actually maybe I could just say
about how I think about this the science
of consciousness so and this relates to
materialism as well because I think the
science of consciousness has to have an
empirical aspect and a theoretical
aspect think some people think you can
just do the empirical bit but I think
you know neuroscience is vital as it is
just gives you correlations to move
beyond that we need to build build a
theory and I think I think a theory of
consciousness should be judged by two
constraints it's going a little bit
beyond what I say in the book actually
and an external constraint and an
internal constraint so the external
constraint is just to fit the data
obviously crucial the internal
constraint is to try and minimize or
ideally eliminate explanatory gaps that
is places in the theory where you're
going from one set of facts to another
with no account of how that happens so
the problem with materialism materialism
isn't just looking at the neuroscience
it's a theory in its own right and it
has an enormous on the face of an
explanatory gap between the quantitative
properties and the qualitative reality
of consciousness I think already the
Russell Eddington view makes progress
there because we now have an
intelligible account of the relationship
between physical states and conscious
states conscious states are the
intrinsic nature of physical States so
I think there's already explanatory
progress there but there's plenty of
work to be done and and so I mean the
crucial next step is how we think about
the relationship between particle
consciousness or consciousness at lower
levels and consciousness at higher
levels is this a causal relationship in
the sense that we need basic laws of
nature to meet to make the gap or is
this a constitutive relationship in the
sense that you know in some sense the
higher level forms of consciousness come
free once you've got the more basic
knowledge consciousness and how do we
make sense of that so there's lots of
you know tricky issues here and there's
already really interesting work going on
so had to hustle murk who's a research
fellow at University of Oslo spent a
year in recently in the lab of Giulio
Tononi who is the founder of the
integrated information theory of
consciousness one of the most best
empirically supported theories of
consciousness working that out in a in
the framework of Russell Eddington pants
psychism and what we end up with is a
view according to which in any system
dekat the consciousness intrinsic nature
is at the level of which is most
integrated information so I think so
this works with the neuroscientific
theory but like any neuro scientific
theory if you've just got the
neuroscience you've just got a
correlation but interpreting it in this
rasa letting the framework moves beyond
the Bur correlation gives you a deeper
explanation you've got well the thing I
talked about in the book the luk Roelofs
who's a University of Bochum reflecting
on whether a split brain patients can
help shed light on mental combinations
so these are the curious cases worthy
people have the corpus callosum in the
middle of their brain split which allows
the two hemispheres communicates of
radical treatment for epilepsy and it
seems to lead to a kind of peculiar
fragmentation of consciousness it ends
up looking like this sort of two
conscious Minds in one person so Roloffs
interest in this is well this brain case
is a kind of the converse of mental
combination and mental combination we're
trying to understand how to stay
conscious subjects can combine to a
single unified conscious objective brain
cases you've got a single conscious mind
fragmenting into multiple conscious
Minds so if we can sort of understand
what's going on in the split brain case
and as it were reverse-engineer it this
might shed light on mental combination
so what we need is philosophers in labs
or philosophers thinking about how do we
make sense of this plan psyches view in
a wave function fundamental view which
have been actually thinking about
actually for something I'm writing for
an oup volume on quantum mechanics and
consciousness so you know I think this
needs to be an interdisciplinary relay
but it's just in its birth and I think
people you know it's going to take it
much more seriously in academic
philosophy although you know you
sometimes people not entirely
comfortable with this but I think rather
than persuading people with the
arguments if we just get on with the
work I think history shows that once you
just get on and start doing some
research and this bears fruit I think
that's when people start to listen a bit
more so so I'm very optimistic but
there's a lot of interesting work to be
done so ya know I like I know know it's
what I was hoping for
it does sound one way or the other
whatever our bets are that's gonna
happen for what's going to happen in the
future I am optimistic that the right
people are beginning to talk to each
other and taking these problems
seriously like I said I am someone who
believes in consciousness as a real
thing I would like to understand it I
don't think that we entirely do final
issue final question very quickly what
do you think how do you conceptualize
the possible moral or ethical
implications of this kind of thing I
know that we can't there's not a simple
road from ought to is but everyone
agrees that science and philosophy
philosophical ideas about consciousness
could have an impact on how we think
about morality and ethics do you have
special thoughts about that yeah a
little bit I took about this a little
bit in in the final more sort of
experimental chapter of the book I mean
first I would say you know of course as
I'm sure you'd agree we shouldn't be
thinking about which view we'd most like
to be true
we should be thinking about review is
most likely to be true and I think
there's you know very good reasons for
taking pants Lakers and seriously is the
best account of how consciousness fits
into nature but I own also inclined to
think that it's maybe of you that's
slightly better for our mental and
spiritual health if the kind of broad
said your materialism is pretty bleak in
a way you know you've got a kind of
mechanistic picture of nature and the
cold immensity of empty space and
whereas you know a bunch like is view we
are conscious creatures in a conscious
universe it's you know it is somewhat we
can feel a little bit perhaps more
comfortable in our own skin and so you
know actually also I think it has the
potential perhaps something I talked
about the book to improve our
relationship to the environment I mean
if you think if you think trees and
plants are just unfeeling mechanisms
then I think inevitably your view of
their value is indirect
their value is indirect in terms of you
know the effect it has on those
conscious creatures looking pretty or
more importantly maintaining our
survival but you know if you think a
tree is a you know in some sense a
conscious entity in its own right then I
think that's a object of immediate moral
concern you know it's a chopping down
trees something that has an immediate
moral focus so I do think perhaps this
gives us you know we're in this
environmental crisis that we can't seem
to deal with for all sorts of reasons
and this might help a little bit and how
we relate to nature in the environment
or locals that shouldn't be the reason
to take it seriously
no that's right you don't you don't
accept a view because you want it to be
true but I think it's perfectly
legitimate to say well I think this view
is true and I'm relieved and happy that
it is I think that's sure perfectly
legit yeah all right thanks so much
there's a lot to think about here Philip
Goff thanks for being on the podcast
thanks a lot so that's been really
enjoyed that vigorous debate thanks for
having me
[Music]